[MUSIC]
Welcome to the your journey preparing for
a career in finance.
Hi, my name is Kirsten Moss.
I am the Dean of Admissions and financial
aid at Stanford Business School, and
we really appreciate you
being with us here today.
This is a panel that is different
from others that we've done.
We really just started panels like this
during the pandemic where we usually would
have a group of students come and talk
about all aspects of the Stanford GSB.
Now we're really diving much deeper.
So I'm looking forward to talking about
specifically your career in finance for
those of you who are interested
either in finance right now or
perhaps are interested in pivoting and
getting your MBA to do that.
We really want to focus on what
your experience could look like,
what the resources are here at the GSB and
how they could help you in the future.
So I am delighted today, I was able
to bring together four students and
usually will have some folks in
the program some graduates recently and
then later graduates, but today I thought
it was really important given this
panel for you to get a taste of four
students who all just graduated.
So they're all class of 2021 have made
their decisions on what they want to do in
the world of finance, and be able to share
with their recent memory what it was like
to be at the GSB, and what helped them
thinking through that transition and
ultimately choosing a career there.
So hopefully that'll be fun for you.
Let me as well I'm going to go ahead and
start looks like we have, all right.
So today's event, we're going to start
with a brief introduction to really talk
about career outcomes at the GSB.
Then I'll give you a chance
to meet the panelists.
Then I will throw to our panelists four or
five questions to get started.
And then really we want to spend
time answering your questions.
So if you put those in the Q&A
there's also an update feature,
we'll make sure we get to the ones
that are most important to you.
And then finally, we will wrap
up at about 55 minutes together.
All right, so if we just take a moment
because this really is focusing on for
those of you who
are interested in finance,
where could your GSB journey take you.
And if you look right now the top
window upon graduation so this was for
the graduating class of 2020.
And this date is on the web if you'd
like to look a little bit more.
You can see what our top five industries
are with finance being at the top,
and within the finance industry 34% of
our students actually decided to take
a career at graduation.
15% in Private Equity 7% in Investment
Management 9 in venture capital and
then we have a mixture of hedge and
investment banking in the other.
Coming into our program,
we actually have about 20% that are in
the investment management, private equity,
VC arena so you can see over time
another 10% of students join them.
If you're currently sitting on the
audience and you're in finance right now,
what you'll see traditionally is about two
thirds of the students coming in Tiffany
who had finance careers,
decide to stay in finance and
they may switch in terms of the arena
that they're practicing that.
So maybe it's PE and BC or someone
may start their own fun for instance.
And then there's about a third of our
students who have finance backgrounds who
decide to go into operating roles.
Maybe they're doing their own startup or
joining a company.
So today in selecting our panelists,
you'll see a little bit of everything to
understand how all of those
different pivots can happen.
And then I want to pause about salary and
be very specific in finance.
I think our average salary upon
graduation is about 160,000.
For finance in particular, the median
is 187,000, and I just wrote it.
You can look on data on the web button PE,
that would be about a 200,000 base 180k
bonus sign on bonus, I'm sorry bonus for
that first year performance expected and
then 43k and signing bonus.
So that gives you a sense of what how your
compensation might change as you evolve
through the GSB.
Another thing to note is our students come
when upon any given year will work both
for their internships upon graduation for
445 different organizations.
And given Stanford's classes only
about 400 students you can see our
students are very targeted and
where they want to go and
there's just a plethora of opportunities.
Unlike perhaps what you might have seen
an undergrad where there are huge feeder
companies that are coming to campus,
here you really will have whether it's
geography industry or location you'll
I mean I'm geography industry or
function you'll have many, many choices.
All right, so it's time to meet
our panelists we have for today.
And as I said,
we've tried to ensure on the panel that
you'd see lots of different backgrounds.
So some you'll hear didn't have
any finance background and
have now pivoted there.
Others came from finance and might be
taking roles in a different industry,
although keeping that finance strong.
Coming from PE and banking perhaps and
going into hedge your search.
So we're going to hear a little
bit more about that right now.
And Daniel, I'm going to start with you
and I'm going to ask you to first tell
us about your role before the GSB,
why you decided to attend, and
I'll pause there because what we find with
our prospects who are coming from finance.
Oftentimes it's hard to give up
the jobs that they already have.
So we're going to hit on that, or
the question that comes up
is how valuable is an MBA?
Do I need to do it?
So for each of you, I'm going to ask
you about your role before the GSB,
why you decided to attend Stanford, and
then what you're going to be doing now,
and how the GSB influenced that
decision over your two years.
>> Perfect, thank you very much Pearson.
So I'm Daniel I was born in Colombia.
Before the GSB I work at Citigroup
in the investment bank and
M&A Latin America group for
two years in America, Mexico City.
And then I moved to Colombia to work for
a higher education startup.
And while doing that,
I started a nonprofit called Mentors4U.
It's a career development program to help
low income college students get the best
jobs in Columbia.
And I was also an adjunct professor
at a local university of social
entrepreneurship theory in Colombia.
I came to the GSB because I did a joint
degree, the MBA master navigation,
which is a very, very unique program ideal
for anyone that wants to be in business
and education role or a leadership role
within an education institution or
doing a startup in irrigation or
investing education.
And during the GSB, I was involved in
everything related to education and
investing in entrepreneurship and
education.
And I just joined as a partner of
an education focus investment fund, and
venture builder called
App Innovation Ventures.
>> Awesome, and Danielle was there
anything at the GSB that helped you in
particular decide that this was
the ultimate job you wanted to take?
>> Sure, so I think so combined the
dynamic form, I think was something that
really, really helped me it wasn't the
education thing of the impacts on that.
And thanks to that, like I learned
everything about kind of early
stage VC investing in education and
thanks for that I met the team at
Owl Ventures which is a tech VC fund
that where our advisor the background.
And I work with them like
volunteer with them part time,
helping them invest in Latin America for
the last two years.
So they actually was the perfect
experiences then go into a more EdTech
focus role.
>> Awesome.
>> So
I think that that was one of the best
experiences for my particular interest.
>> Great thanks so much.
Georgie, how about I start with you next?
Your role before the GSB
why you decided to come and
what you're doing now, and then how
the GSB helped you figure that out.
>> Sure, hi everyone, I'm Georgie.
Before the GSB, I worked for two years
in investment banking at JP Morgan,
and then I worked for
two years in private equity at TPG.
I worked specifically at TPG Growth and
the Rise Fund,
which is TBG social impact fund.
I came to Stanford.
It's fighting back now, but
I came for a few reasons.
Coming out of private equity, I definitely
struggled with what Kirsten was talking
about of feeling as though
in my current spot.
I had a number of attractive
opportunities that I wanted to pursue.
I knew I loved investing.
From my current role I had opportunities
to continue in private equity or
go directly to work at a hedge fund,
which is what I was most interested in.
So the decision to trade off
between going directly to these
great opportunities versus going to
business school was a tough one for me.
It was solved and not to be too cute here,
but really when I got into Stanford, for
me, I wasn't sure that any business
school would be the right choice.
But Stanford seemed to me to really have
an x-factor that would make it incredibly
impactful both for my professional
life and also my personal life.
Professionally because
just seeing examples,
it's such a small elite community.
Where I heard time and time again that,
by meeting professors or
leaving classmates, people ended up
pursuing careers they hadn't dreamed up.
One example is the legendary
Professor McDonald,
who through his mentorship and
connecting people to the bass family.
There, with sprouted TPG, SPO, and
essentially five massive, massive firms.
And so it just seemed like a place that
was really an accelerator of connecting
talented people and resources to
create a really exciting new path.
And so I thought that yes,
I want to work in a hedge fund or so
I thought but
let me at least go spend these
two years opening opportunities
in case I don't want to do that.
And then personally, Stanford just has
such a unique culture I've heard it
referred to as a personal boot camp and
I would definitely second that.
I thought it would be a great place to
really reflect on my experiences and
refine sort of what my strengths and
weaknesses were and
what I really wanted out of my career.
So I can make a good choice
coming out of my two years there.
So that was why I chose Stanford.
After school or now I'm working on what's
called a search fund which is basically
raising money to go out and
buy a business.
And in terms of how
the GSB influenced that,
the GSB was pivotal in that decision.
I came into my second year having done
an internship and Investment Management at
fidelity, thinking for
sure I want to work at a hedge fund.
My winter quarter I stumbled
into a search fund class.
Never having heard what a search fund was,
and
then meeting those professors kind
of falling into that network,
the search fund really was born
out of Stanford and arose back.
I kind of fell in love with it, and it
felt like a great fit for my skills, but
also what I really wanted out of a career,
and kind of taking risk at this point.
So, without Stanford,
I'm not sure if I would be doing this, and
so I'm really grateful for the experience.
>> Awesome, thank you Georgie.
How about Jessica, we turn it over to you.
>> Yeah, of course.
Hi, Nice to meet everyone.
I'm Jessica originally from Salvador,
Brazil and
most recently prior to the GSB,
I was at Palantir.
So I worked there and should have
a myriad of like product management,
business development focus specifically on
the government side of the business, so
very much not finance.
And then before that I worked at a law
firm because once upon a time I thought I
wanted to be a lawyer so
also like really not finance.
So I came in and was what we
affectionately call the the GSB,
the triple B's.
So I took base accounting, base finance,
the base like I forgot even
the other classroom kind of taught.
[LAUGH] So it was like really like did
not know anything coming in to the GSB
if you ask me what an income statement
was, I would probably run away crying.
So that's just to level set how
little I knew about finance.
And now I work in venture capital.
I work in early stage venture, invest in
seed through series C, although my fund
actually just raised the growth funds
we'll also do that coming shortly.
And I guess a couple of the things
I think are worth mentioning one,
I think the GSB was phenomenal in terms
of giving me a financial education so
I feel very confident now.
With basically anything related to
finance I was able to build upon I had
a fantastic intro to finance class.
When I first started the GSB was
able to build on top of that and
take a bunch of finance classes that,
further specialise and
deepen my knowledge throughout the GSB.
And I thought GSBwas just really great
at helping me gain that knowledge.
There were many like tutoring
opportunities after classes so
that I could beef up my knowledge and so
I was coming in at like a very
low Level of finance knowledge.
in general,
like all the classmates were really
helpful professors were really helpful.
So I would just say particularly for
any one of you who are thinking of
going to a career in finance and
kind of nervous about how you're going to
do that, if you don't have the experience.
I think the MBA is really
just fantastic for that and
the GSE in particular really, really
prepared me for a career in finance.
So I think that's sort of number one,
and then Christine,
please remind me of the other question.
>> Yeah, you've answered them.
How did you decide to go
into venture capital and
was there anything that
particularly helped you?
>> Yeah, so I always love technology.
So I when I worked with a law firm,
I worked in intellectual property.
Obviously palantir is very, I wasn't
really a startup at the time I joined like
very much in the world of tech and I
always thought it was really interesting.
But I kind of realized that I
didn't necessarily want to do being
an operator for the long term and
that is like working in startups.
And I just love the idea
of helping people and
helping people sort of
achieve their dreams.
And I thought that working
in venture was a way for
me to pair up with
a bunch of entrepreneurs.
And help them sort of build great
companies and to give the skills that I
have, which is sort of helping
people achieve their potential.
And having sort of like a clear and
logical mind and
like spotting trends and
like helping in that way.
So I thought it was sort of a good fit for
what I was interested in and
sort of the skills I had, and
then the skills that I built at the GSB.
And at the GSB, I got really involved
in the venture capital club.
It was the president of
the venture capital club and
really lucky I got to meet
with a bunch of venture funds.
I think for anyone going to venture
there's I personally don't think that
there's another business school that
can hold like a candle to the GSB.
Like you just see the entire Sandhill
road venture funds like coming in and
desperate to GSB years.
They all want to know what what
your classmates are starting and
what you're doing and what's happening on
campus like it's very thriving ecosystem.
And so it was kind of like a no brainer
since I thought I wanted to do venture to
go to the GSB.
And then that very much proved true
once I went to the GSB I was just like,
absolutely the best
place I could have been.
And kind of like had my pick of
jobs like once I graduated and
pick this fun that I really loved and
interned over the summer.
I guess the other thing I would say that
was really helpful is I have a lot of
classmates from college that
went to their business schools.
That didn't necessarily have the best
experience with the Career Services at
the other schools.
And I on the other hand,
like could sing praises to this.
There's this one person called
Tom who's like the person for
venture capital at the GSB.
And I mean like he would
answer my emails in a minute.
I would call him like freaking out before
interviews on a Saturday and he would
be there and she Cheering on me just like
really incredible people in support so.
I mean like have nothing but
amazing things to say about
the GSB when it came to that,.
Particularly given I had like
no background no network
because I'm Brazilian like really
didn't know people like just you
really helped me set me up well for
going into VC Awesome.
Thank you, Jessica.
How about you?
>> Yeah, sure.
So, before business school,
I did a smattering of different things,
I worked at so
really in private equity out of college.
I'm doing kind of technology buyouts.
I left to start my own company,
which was education marketplace.
I did that for two years.
After selling that I worked at
China's largest wealth manager,
sourcing growth stage,
US technology deals.
So, throughout all of those I
knew my passion was technology.
I had seen companies at basically
every stage from idea stage to
growth stage to late stage buyout.
And I have actually similar to Georgie,
I have read this article online.
I might post it in the chat,
about several GSB investors in the 70s and
80s.
That came from Jack McDonald but
others too, including an investment
group of Santa Barbara and I said wow,
these are some amazing investors.
They're not as well covered as
Warren Buffett, but in my mind,
I wanted to be like them, and
they focused on technology and
they had a long term view of the world.
And so that's why I came to GSB.
I said, maybe I'll have a shot and
becoming like them,
if I go to this school.
And I actually came in with that focus,
which I never really felt prior.
And it was reaffirmed to me within
the first six months of GSB.
Mostly through other classmates.
I think something that a lot
of people don't talk about,
is the breadth of experiences,
that the classmates have at GSB.
Whether that's deep and venture capital or
whether that's like Jessica,
[INAUDIBLE] and just seeing all aspects
of technology helped me figure out that I
really wanted to be on
the investment side long term.
And basically do that and
this opportunity at Citadel.
I work there between first and
second year, was kind of the last part
of the tech lifecycle that I
haven't explored public markets.
And so I took that up in the summer.
This was during Covid which was
an interesting uncertain time.
And I really enjoyed it.
And there my logic was very similar to
the reason why I came to GSB, which was,
the people I met were
the smartest people I could find.
And also I could spend a lot of time with
them and still be happy and be myself,
which I think is very important.
And I found that to be true during
the three months at Citadel,
in the summer so
I returned and started here.
And I would say the second thing, that I
probably haven't seen the benefits of yet,
but I will soon or later in life is
a lot of the non-finance courses at GSB.
Which is a big reason I came, touchy
feely and interpersonal dynamics and
other courses.
And I think in finance sometimes
we underestimate the importance of
teamwork and evaluating people.
Even building teams within
financial organizations,
and Stanford does an amazing job of that.
And I would say that's something not
to dismiss when you're thinking about,
Stanford in the lens of finance and
probably something people
don't talk about enough.
>> Fantastic, thank you.
What I love about hearing from all of
you is such different backgrounds and
still going in different paths but
finding things at the GSB
that helped you get there.
Let's take a make a bridge
from your last answer Shih and
one of the things I did want to ask was,
what was an academic course or experience
that is really helped you or you think
will help you in your current job?
Or as [INAUDIBLE] said and your next
steps and it could be in finance or
it could have been something like
touchy feely, but what pops for
you academic course or experience?
How about I start back with you, Daniel.
Sure, and I want to highlight what
said about the the soft skills and
interpersonal aspect.
For me the most unique experience of
the GSB was being an Arbuckle Fellow.
And for those of you that you don't
know what an Arbuckle Fellow,
it's a program where you're
basically trained as a coach, and
as a mentor, and then you have
the opportunity to receive coaching.
And mentorship from professional
coaches throughout the year, and
then you become the coach to eight,
first years.
And basically that experience which
was an incredibly introspection,
self development of self awareness,
personal development,
how I impact others how others impact me.
Just having that awareness was incredibly,
I think it represents what the GSB is,
which is just world class finance and
operations and
entrepreneurship materials with
an experiences and classes.
But just combine that with this.
It's touchy felineness,
it's incredibly unique.
And this is what I think what we need
more in finance, in the industry.
So, I think that that's the thing that
I say is [INAUDIBLE] how we could take
an investment class or a search on garage,
which is l that I took with Georgie.
That type of class finance and
entrepreneurship, and then combined
with more touchy feely Arbuckle fellow
like does this go to mentality and
just having that versatility of being
able to go to one side or the other.
The more logical to the more emotional and
just be able to adapt
to whatever person we're dealing with or
whatever situation we have.
>> Awesome.
How about Jessica, come back to you.
>> Yeah, I would definitely highlight
the the soft skills classes we have.
We have a bunch.
So in your first year, you do something
called the leadership labs and
you get to interact with fellow
classmates and you get recorded and
you see sort of how you
interact in a group.
And then there's touchy feely class
which is interpersonal dynamics,
which is also sort of a deep dive into the
quite literally interpersonal dynamics and
relationships.
I think that's really helpful because
obviously a career in finances
you have to know finance but
you also, there's so
much about the people element right
like finances is most of the time.
Even in hedge funds, you're still
meeting with companies and the CEOs and
getting to build relationships with them,
but most finances,
you're investing in a company,
you're meeting with entrepreneurs.
Or you're meeting with a CEO and
you're getting to know people, and
you're in the business with people, and
I think that's sometimes not highlighted
by folks who think about what is
going to be your financial education.
And so I think that Learning how to really
interact with people is really important.
And I think on the more
hard skill classes,
I think one of the classes that
I really loved I took this sort
of legendary financial modeling class
from a professor called de Marzo.
In that work you want to sell your soul
to that class for a quarter but again,
I came from knowing absolutely nothing,
again I would open an Excel sheet and
come running to the other side.
And cry to be able to completely model and
LBO like an entire waterfall of VC returns
and feel really confident with that.
That's, I think,
some pretty crazy transformation for
sitting three months in a classroom and
in my case, over zoom, join us.
So you do really go very well
equipped to go into the career.
>> Awesome.
Thank you, Jessica.
And I'm guessing about half of our
audience is in your position of,
I want to be in finance and
haven't done it.
So it's really helpful.
And just one other comment before
Jessica was talking about base classes,
when you come in there is
a required curriculum at the GSB.
And there are three different levels.
So for those of you who
haven't seen finance before,
you'll go into the base and for
those of you may be more like George's
background who was was an banking and
private equity.
You'll go into that very top
level of the finance class,
because we want to customize
it to what your learning is.
Georgie, I'm going to come back to you.
One of the things that is very special
about the GSB is all the experiential
classes, Startup Garage,
Interpersonal Dynamics that.
And one of our newest courses is
this startups search fund, and
now you're doing a search fund.
Any highlight you can give the audience so
they understand what it means
to do something experiential, and also
finance, bringing both of those together?
And I'll say one more thing, at Stanford,
you will read case studies as a student
and you'll recommend to the protagonist,
if you write a write up on
the case what they should do.
But we also want you to be
the protagonist of your own life.
So we want to give you the skills
to go out and do things,
not just read about it and
tell other people what to do.
So I'd love to get your insights
on how that course went.
>> Yeah, that was a fantastic course.
And I'm sure that Adeni can jump in here,
too.
That was my first actually
really experiential course,
where I was the subject of
the course in my experience.
And essentially, the goal of that class
was to come out at the end of it ready
to launch a search fund.
And we had three professors who, all three
are excellent practitioners in this space.
And then the class was a number
of classmates who were
really passionate about this, and
ready to hit the ground running, but
also in very different stages.
Some were sort of at the beginning
stage of figuring out,
do I want to do a search fund?
And some had already figured out they
want to do it and had raised capital.
I was sort of closer to the latter group,
and I actually have been working
with a fund and we had found
a deal that we wanted to pursue.
So I'd been looking at that for
three months before the class started, and
then during that class, essentially was
working through the process of selling
the founder to sell their company to
us and also diligencing the company.
And then also, just thinking more broadly,
is this an investment thesis I really
want to pursue, and am I working with
people that I really want to work with?
And it was a fascinating experience,
because often we would just bring our
problems to the classroom and
we would just discuss it in open forum.
And I remember one of them was that,
I had all these diligence questions that
I wanted to get to the bottom of, and
I felt that we were taking too long to ask
very basic questions about financials.
And you would present
that to the class and
some of the feedback I would get was so
enlightening.
And people would say, well,
actually the sales process and
building relationships with
the seller is far more important.
It's not like private equity where
you can say, send these 15 files.
It really is much more of an EQ
exercise versus an IQ exercise.
And it was so cool to be
learning that live in class, and
also build an incredible relationship with
my professors, who now have become mentors
because they saw me sort of
work through these questions.
And so that class was really instrumental
in me kind of learning what is it really
like to pursue a search fund and also get
comfort with doing that after school.
>> Awesome, Ishin, I'm going to ask
you one question, too, what I realize,
given your PE background,
a specific question.
We have 15% of our students going into PE,
another 7 in investment management.
So in that whole arena,
it's really one of the biggest pathways.
I have a great friend in career services,
like Jessica was talking about.
So Bill Thompson, I know is our PE guru,
and he usually says, if someone's coming
from an I banking or PE background,
they have no problem securing a job.
But just given none of you are doing that
right out, it might be a big interest.
Do you have any insights from friends or
others at Silver Lake or
other firms in how they
were able to secure jobs?
>> Yeah, that's not a problem at all.
I think there's more jobs than
students at USB in general,
so,if you want to do PE, you can do it.
I would also emphasize that I still
found value in the accounting courses,
just to wrap up and tie a lot of loose
ends that maybe you learned on the job,
but it's good to know
the academic part of it.
So that's a shout out to Ron Cosnic
there on the accounting side.
And the survey courses,
because in PE you come from a specific
style of private equity, and
it's good to see leaders and
other styles or other sizes of deals.
And so Finance 207 was a survey course
I took, that was really helpful for
me to see different styles of investing,
to find where I wanted to be,
even if that's within PE, there's so
many different ways to do it now.
>> Will you tell us, I don't know what
207 is, and so I'm really curious, too.
When you say survey, what do you mean?
>> We had different speakers come
from different parts of finance and
it was just amazing.
Not only the students you can talk to and
learn from them, but
you learn from the speakers
telling their life stories.
So we had distressed investing guys.
We had growth equity investors.
We had venture capitalists.
So we were able to see people
at the top of their field,
how they thought differently.
And that helped me figure
out where I fit in, too.
>> That's awesome.
All right, I'm going to start going
to some of the questions that are in our
Q and A, keeping an eye on the time.
So I'll read one from,
I think it's Michael.
As international students,
are we required to apply to a specific
program if we want to pursue
a career in PS at a US based firm?
So this is a great actual question.
We have two internationals on the panel
today, nd it comes up a lot of how much
harder is it for international students to
get working authorization in the states.
And if you can speak to you or
your friends,
how they thought about that question?
So Danielle, you want to start with that?
>> Sure, so if y'all know that now the GSB
has the three year STEM extension,
so if we want to stay in the US,
we can stay abroad for
three years if we're working
in STEM related fields.
So that's a huge plus.
And then it all depends on the firm, but
I would say that most investing firms,
that have a good size,
they accept internationals.
And my friends that are staying from Latin
America, they're staying in the US and
doing investing, they'll have their visas,
those companies can sponsor their visa.
So I think there's, maybe has to be
a boutique company that very few people,
they have the admin or they just
don't want to hire international for
some reason, but
I actually haven't heard about it.
So I would say that for P, NBC, probably,
most of them will hire internationals.
>> That's great, anything else,
Jessica, from your perspective?
>> Yeah, so in my case,
I was fortunate enough to get a green
card right when I started school.
So I wasn't subject to sort of H-1B
international rules, but I was,
when I was at Yale.
And I think the H-1B, honestly again,
I think a lot of the bigger
companies will sponsor an H-1B.
But as Daniel said,
there are many smaller boutique that are
starting to understand the H-1B better.
I think the big problem a lot
of times with the H-1B,
when you first graduate college,
so not for business school,
when you first graduate college is
that you're in the regular pool.
The regular pool is a much lower chance
of you getting the H-1B visa lottery.
Once you finish your master's,
it's actually so much easier to get
the lottery, because you double dip into,
you have a priority just for master's and
then you double dip, because you can
also be eligible for the post college,
sort of the just bachelor's lottery.
And because the GSB gives the STEM
extension for three years, that means
you're eligible, basically, after your
OPT for every year over the three years.
So it's much easier to stay, and I think
As long as you are able to communicate
that to companies, companies then feel
totally fine spending, basically,
the investment to get you
to stay in the US because,
obviously, you're GSB so
they want to keep you here.
>> Awesome, the next question I
want to is from Enrique talk about
because I've met a bunch of folks in
the audience have this question, as well.
He was saying that starting a FinTech
company requires many skills.
And we do know that, as I said,
about a third of folks coming in
with finance backgrounds end
up going into operating roles.
So, the question is, how does the GSB
program help you with these other skills,
tech, product management, legal?
What it's like to be an entrepreneur?
So I'm going to look back to Ishan because
I know you founded your own company, and
you know what it takes on both sides.
You have them both in your career and
maybe you can speak to that.
>> Yeah, and
I've invested in a lot of FinTechs too.
So I can talk a bit about that, but
it all comes down to the people skills.
Building a company is just a group of
people that believe the same thing.
And it's those core skills at
GSB that you get to practice.
You don't just learn from a textbook,
starting in the first quarter.
That will be the most useful in
starting a company, in my mind.
And, I think the idea will change,
most likely.
But working that through
with your classmates,
pitching them, there's even student
VC funds that you can pitch and
get your ideas vetted from,
that's really valuable.
But I would say, first and foremost
is finding co-founders, practicing
what your pitch is, building a team,
and figuring out what your mission is.
Which are all non-finance related things
are important for starting a company, so.
>> And that's a great segue, Ishan.
Many of our classes like startup garage or
Georgie talked about startup search fund,
but startup garage or design for extreme
affordability, any of those classes
have the student become, again,
the protagonist actually create a company.
Anybody take one of those
outside of Georgie's class and
talk about what that's like?
Anybody here did startup garage?
No, maybe I'll say a moment,
because all those things, Ishan,
you were saying, I know you've done it
before, because you were the entrepreneur.
But a group of about 46 students will come
together in a startup garage and they'll
decide on what's the problem they want to
solve in order to graduate that course.
The class action, the final class is,
what's the prototype?
So, you really will get very hands-on
figuring out, who could be my co-founder?
What's the problem we want to solve and
how do we actually deliver
a product that will do that?
Awesome, let's go to the next.
Is there anybody else who thinks about how
you get entrepreneurial skills at Stanford
or Daniel, you're launching, yeah, you're
actually building companies right now.
What would you say?
>> No, I would say like just the when
I think about my GSB experience,
I think academics are maybe 20 to 25%.
I think just the things outside
of academics and formal classes,
that's what the real experience is,
I think.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So just every BBL every launch you can
go to, hear from entrepreneurs,
hear from investors,
you're learning there from them,
I started there.
And then just the things that you
can do part-time, on the side,
volunteering, part-time work,
doing projects with companies,
that's where, and especially for
us during pandemic, that was huge.
So, a little suggestion to anyone that
either wants to have the investing or
entrepreneurial experiences,
try to do something on the side,
some sort of project.
And you will be amazed with your
staffer email saying your ideas.
Why you're interested
in this sort of thing?
Talking to an entrepreneur or
a certain firm, or a certain company,
doing something with them,
that's where you will learn the most.
And then combining that experience with
your actual classes that combination
is huge.
And even working with other classmates.
And we have, I don't know, 20 classmates
that have already launched their own
companies, some of them
during the pandemic.
Just like you can do that,
you can do your on-the-side project and
just working well starting I think
it's if you are able to manage it.
I think is just the best
way to learn on the go and
put all these entrepreneurial
experiences for your benefit.
>> Awesome, and
I will just to cap what Daniel was saying,
actually 18% of students launched
companies last year, which is amazing.
So you're going to be surrounded by role
models who are really interested in that.
And Poets and
Funks did an article that looked back
over the last five graduating classes.
So just go back over the last five years.
And if you look at the top 100 students
from any business school who launched
a company,
ours was almost half of the list.
And we raised more money than all the
other ones put together like 1.6 billion,
1.7 billion.
And that's just people who are Ishan,
and Daniel, and Jessica, and
Georgie's really stage of
career plus a couple years.
So, you will be inspired
by the people around you.
I have one more quick question from
Charles, what are some of the most
effective ways to gain practical
investing experience at the GSB?
And also, what are some of the avenues
available to students who want to raise
money to start their own fund?
So, I don't know,
who would like to answer that,
ways to get investing experience or
raising money?
>> I can jump in, to start off.
So, I would say a good way to
get investing experience is,
sorry, is the Finance and Investment Club.
And this club is a group of
people who love investing.
We have regular stock pitches, sorry,
I was one of the presidents, so
we had stock pitches.
We would have an investment committee
where people would pitch a stock, and
then we would all sort of discuss,
poke holes, and
kind of help refine that
person's investment thesis.
And then we also ran
a pretty substantial fund.
I forget exactly,
maybe Ishan you know, but
I think it was over $300,000 where we
would actually test the students' ideas.
And so that was a great
way to practice investing.
Get feedback from your peers and
then also get feedback from the market.
I would also say that sort of,
Ishan mentioned this in his comment too.
There are a number of ways to get
practical experience while you're at
school, given that we're in the heart of
Silicon Valley and right by San Francisco.
There are so many people who
are looking to tap into GSB talent, and
there are tons of
opportunity from alumni or
people in the network to actually intern
during the year or do part-time work.
And that's a great way to
learn from an investor and
get practical experience
while you're at school.
>> Awesome, great, now I'm going to
turn it back to the panelists.
And if you could give some advice
to someone who's in the audience.
What I say is, oftentimes,
people tell me, as the dean,
that I won't get in,
I don't know if I should apply.
And I'm always like, just do it,
you're never going to know unless you put
yourself out there and do the application.
So, for
someone who's thinking about applying,
maybe even this fall, any tips you
would give them in that process?
And I'll start with Jessica.
>> Yeah, for sure, I think very much
underscoring that you should just apply,
you can always apply again,
[LAUGH] if not.
But I think a couple of things one is,
on preparing for
the GMAT, obviously, is important,
but don't go crazy over it.
I think that there's so much stress all
the time over the standardized tests and
I really think that just like.
Getting to know Kiersten and
getting to know sort of the GSB
it's definitely a school that's
focused a lot on the holistic student.
Obviously like not in the admissions but
I definitely felt that when
I was doing my interviews.
And once I got my admissions letter,
one of the things that they were focusing
on was not the GMAT score a lot or my GPA.
It was a lot around my experiences and
how I thought about my vision for
what I wanted to do.
I think the thing that I would suggest for
people to keep in mind is think
about what the GSB motto is and
what the GSB is trying to do in terms of
the leaders that they want to nurture.
And how we want to really change
organizations, change lives,
change the world.
And think about very seriously
how you intend to do that and
how you're going to use your MBA to
not just further your own career, but
also how you really hope to
make an impact in the world.
And thinking around that and I think
that really helps you become a lot more
inspired to apply and
think about the impact you want to have.
If you're not just worried about,
my God, I have to get this GMAT score.
And so trying to think a little more about
the future and not just the short term,
like how do I get through the application
process, I think, is important.
>> Awesome, thanks Jessica.
How about you Georgie, what would you say?
>> I would definitely
echo Jessica's comments.
And I think what I would say is that
the process can be incredibly daunting,
but if you try to make the effort,
it actually, at least for me,
was a process of great self-discovery,
especially the GSB application.
One piece of advice I would give people
is often people try to game the system or
feel that there's a correct
answer you have to give.
And what I would say is definitely,
especially for the GSB app,
give the answer that is
most authentic to you.
I think that way you put out an
application that you can feel good about
regardless of the outcome.
And frankly, personally I'm sure I can say
it's probably more of what the GSB wants
to see, wants people to be really
authentic and bring themselves.
And so that's what I would say is
sometimes you have to tune out the noise
and put out an application that you feel
is really true to yourself rather than
what you think you should be or be saying.
>> Awesome.
And I remember Georgia you were
a classics major, is that right?
And yeah, so many times-
>> Good memory.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah, I remember, I remember
your essays and everything, yeah.
>> Wow.
>> But it's not about presenting
this finance person who's presenting
Georgie and
who Georgie is what she cares about.
So it's great advice.
>> How about you Ishan,
what would you say?
>> Yeah,
I would echo everyone's points, but
also add to take the writing
portion seriously.
Try different drafts,
don't try to write it in one day.
But also don't try to create
a shell of who you think you are.
And I think that process of figuring out,
hey, this reflects who I am, and
come back to it and see it again,
will help you realize a lot more about
yourself and give you clarity even
before going to any MBA program.
That's what happened to me.
And so the exercise is valuable,
but yeah go ahead
>> Ishan, I was going to say,
is there anything you could speak to?
because I bet a bunch of folks
are actually starting to write that essay,
anything that you concretely did
to help you do some of that.
You said you did multiple drafts, but-
>> I did multiple versions.
So first I tried to answer the prompt
directly and simply, I remember.
And then I read it the next day and
I said, hey,
this sounds like what they want to hear,
but doesn't sound like me.
So I'm just going to try to change it and
I started using more I statements,
and things we learned at GSB,
but I didn't know yet.
>> [LAUGH] That's great.
>> And that was valuable, but I wasn't
sure if that's how I should submit a,
quote unquote, professional school essay,
but I just went with it.
And now I realized that's probably
the best way to go with it.
Because I was admitted for
who I am, basically, and
that's what makes leaders unique.
And something I learned at GSB is
those parts that make us who we are.
So letting yourself show through those,
through I statements and
giving personal anecdotes and small
stories, I think is really important.
Instead of just saying, hey,
this is who I am, this is why I'm perfect,
because nobody's perfect.
>> Well said.
And we may be a little different
than other schools, so I want you to
be careful to do your homework as
you're submitting other schools essays.
But at the GSB I can promise you
we don't really care what you say
is your aspiration in terms of
whether you're admitted or not.
So if you've never been in finance like
Jessica and you say I want to go into
venture capital, we're not going to say,
she could never do it.
We really believe that if you come
to the GSB with the community and
with all that you'll bring here, you will
find a way to meet your aspiration to
fulfill your dreams as they were.
It may not be immediately,
it may be a pivot down the road,
but we know you'll get there.
So feel free to just speak to what you
really think will be your true North and
we know that's going to evolve over time.
But at this point in time, is there
something, some problem you want to solve,
something you care about, something
you want to work on as an aspiration.
That's really what we want to know.
So Daniel, how about you?
>> I like everything that's been said.
I think authenticity just
is very important and
just think why are you unique.
What makes you unique?
And we're all unique, so
really tell me what makes you unique
versus anyone else that is applying.
And normally, the professional side,
we all kind of go to companies,
work in company different roles, but
normally the unique stuff are in
the most on the personal side.
And that's where I think
where the more emotions and
more powerful story comes when
you kind of reflect on that.
Normally, the things that have happened to
you and that have impacted in your life
mostly come on those personal or
non-professional things,
that maybe some of them are also
in the professional stuff.
You can maybe complement, but just
reflecting on really what drives you and
what matters most and
what you want to do in the future.
What are the things you want to work on
during this two year experience, and just
trying to enjoy that process, not seeing
it as this is an essay I have to write.
This is a reflection process.
I'm given the opportunity to reflect about
my life and why I want to go to this.
This is not an MBA, this is a leadership
and personal development program.
It's an opportunity to be more self aware,
more introspective, to learn from
diversity, from others and be able to
also support others in their journeys.
So just understanding what
the GSB experience is about,
which really that's what
makes this school unique.
This is not an MBA,
it's a personal leadership,
that's what I think is the most
unique thing about this program.
So once you read, talk with alumni,
talk with students,
read the articles that GSB puts out.
Read about the classes and
you understand those values and
you read about the values and
the ethos of the school and
you understand that that's
what makes this school unique.
That's where you maybe you
start relaxing and say,
well, like let's connect on that and let's
see what are the things that connect me
to those things that the GSB
say they care about.
Because the values and the things
Christine talks about in the articles she
writes and in the interviews that has been
published about them, that that's true.
It's about that, it's not about
the GMAT and GPA and all this stuff.
There's many people with that and a lot of
those high grades and stuff don't get in,
and people like me that got 60 points
below the average or 80 points below
the average in the GMAT got in maybe
because there's a story around that.
And just to highlight the GMAT aspect,
I almost didn't apply to the GSB,
almost didn't apply.
A lot of my friends didn't apply because
they got lower than average GMATs, and
that's incredibly sad.
Because this school looks for
that thing that makes you special, and
that's your leadership potential.
And that GMAT normally,
it like a GMAT is a score, it's an exam.
That doesn't define your
leadership potential.
So I'll encourage everyone to please
apply and please be authentic and
just tell your unique story and
just enjoy this reflection process of
going throughout through this essay.
>> Awesome.
I'm looking,
we have just two more minutes.
That was great tips and
one thing I realized we haven't talked
a lot about directly is the community.
So anybody want to speak to what surprised
the most because I always say we're like
a family and people support you.
But coming from me, I think it's a little
hard to believe at times, [LAUGH] so
you guys have experienced it.
But anyone want to put their hand up and
talk about what surprised the most about
becoming part of this, TSP family?
Do all volunteer one?
>> Yeah, I can do a quick.
>> There's your hand, thanks.
>> Yeah,
we have a special portal for alumni.
And so I reached out during my
first year for six months, keynote,
maybe 20 different alumni.
And I think the average response
was probably half a day,
regardless of role,
responsibility, function.
So the network the community is so
tight knit, it's pretty incredible.
And as alumni,
I think we feel an obligation to support
those that are coming after us and
support the community.
I saw that firsthand, I think I'm still
about to see that the benefits and
the fruits of that, but it's really true.
And I think you're right, Kirsten to say
that it has to come from the students.
>> [LAUGH]
>> because I didn't really believe it
until I saw it, so like cool stuff.
>> So awesome,
anybody else want to, Jessica?
>> Yeah, happy to jump in sort of two
points that I think are interesting.
One is to just double-click on what
Sean said, as a great example.
I remember when I got into the GSB and
I wanted to explore a career
in venture capital.
I decided that I was
going to go on LinkedIn and
I searched general partner
plus Stanford GSB on LinkedIn.
And I reached out to approximately
45 people saying that
I had just been admitted.
So just to start in the fall, gave them my
background will love to talk to them for
like 20 minutes or get a coffee,
whatever they wanted.
Just to learn a little more and
get to understand VC imagining, of course,
that maybe five people would reply
to me and so that would be fine.
It turns out that every single one of
the 45 people replied and were like,
absolutely, I'll meet with you come for
coffee and no come to my office,
it was really enthusiastic.
So I actually ended up taking
a week off from my job because so
many people have replied and we're excited
to meet you that I did like a tour of,
[LAUGH] Sand Hill Road.
And was going to all of these offices
into coffee at coupon coffee or whatever.
Because everyone was so
excited to talk to me.
And I think that that was already like
a very, very clear example of how
much the alums are there for you and
how tight the GSB community is.
And I think that's also true at
the GSB while you're a student
just the level of support and
love that exists between all the students.
So many people that say you had
a difficult family emergency,
which happened to me during school.
Just everyone will rise up to
the occasion, and support you, and
find ways to help you, and
show up with bagels at your house.
And it's just really such an incredible
community and it's really unparalleled
to anything I've ever seen in my
GSB classmates are my best friends.
And I know they'll be my best friends for
life.
So I think both on like a personal level
and also on the professional level,
it's really a tight knit community.
>> Awesome, well,
that's a great comment to wrap up on.
I want to thank you so much Jessica,
Daniel, Sean, Georgie.
It's so fun to see you after reading all
of your applications live on the screen.
So I really appreciate your support and
for those of you in the audience,
thank you for joining us.
And good luck if you're putting in
an application we hope to get to know you
better soon.
Have a great day.
[MUSIC]